this video was made possible by
Skillshare home to over 16,000 classes
that could teach you a new life skill
the first 500 people to sign up using
the link in the description will get a 2
month free trial
you're probably wondering why you're
seeing me outside versus an animated cow
to most modern Americans the great
outdoors is seen less as a way of life
and more of a novelty reserved for
vacations or hiking trips most of us in
the West live a box lifestyle we wake up
in an air-conditioned box hop in a
smaller air conditioned box then sit in
a box surrounded by other boxes in an
even larger box on any given workday we
might spend less than half an hour
outside this is obviously in stark
contrast to how humans have lived for
tens of thousands of years since the
Agricultural Revolution and to a lesser
extent since the advent of widespread
farming our diet and habits have changed
drastically our technological progress
has outpaced evolution among our species
and that's come with a whole assortment
of health problems take America for
example nearly 10% of Americans have
some form of diabetes double the rate of
just 20 years ago 36 and a half percent
of American adults over one-third of
every adult in the country are obese
40 million adults suffer from depression
over six hundred and ten thousand
Americans die of heart disease every
year that's one in every four deaths of
course these problems don't just come
from the fact that we don't go outside
enough this overall decline in health
has been caused by three overarching
lifestyle changes away from our
hunter-gatherer roots diet habitat and
movement our ancestors were nomadic and
traveled all across Africa's Great Rift
Valley in search of plentiful food
sources and new places to live the
lowlands of Africa were early man's
habitats and while they traveled large
distances for food or shelter they never
really experienced any extreme changes
in their overall habitat the past 200
years humanity's technological progress
has allowed us to change all that on
September 5th 1862 two British men made
history by breaking the previous
altitude record for a hot air balloon
flight over the course of the next hour
James glacier and Henry Coxwell ascended
to somewhere between 35 and 39 thousand
feet the exact measurement is unknown
because glacier stopped taking readings
when his vision failed shortly before he
passed out from lack of oxygen these two
men had entered an environment which no
human in history had ever experienced
the planets upper atmosphere 39,000 feet
is over seven miles in the air
that's higher than Mount Everest and
higher even than the typical cruising
altitude of 747s it was an environment
completely inhospitable to human life
somewhere biologically speaking our
species was never meant to go the
Industrial Revolution was the catalyst
for an entirely new trajectory of human
experience hot air balloons air ships
and planes opened up the skies diving
bells suits and submarines allowed us to
explore the depths of the world's oceans
oxygen tanks allowed climbers to reach
the highest mountain peaks and finally
rocket technology allowed us to leave
the earth entirely and enter the void of
outer space the Industrial Revolution
and the breakthroughs that followed
allowed humans to experience extreme new
environments and many explorers died as
a result this showed us not only the
limits of human biology but also helped
us understand what features make a
habitat habitable while we humans are
very good at preventing death even in
extreme environments if we wanted to
design a hospitable habitat from scratch
we would need to keep in mind three key
points based on our evolution first
humans evolved with a certain habitat
feature remaining constant all the time
at the same level gravity our bodies are
heavily dependent on the forces of
gravity which is why astronauts
typically don't stay in space for very
long second our species evolved with a
more or less constant cyclical habitat
feature the day/night cycle the
day/night cycle breaks up the human
lifetime with reasonable periods of
activity and rest which is why we begin
to feel sick or uncomfortable if we mess
with our sleep schedule too much the
advent of the light bulb and the option
of staying awake long after the Sun had
gone down was a huge lifestyle change
that happened not too long ago in the
timeline of human evolution finally our
species evolved with a handful of
habitats features that varied within a
reasonable range temperature migration
and weather when we stay cooped up
inside all day watching TV or browsing
reddit we tend to feel physically
uncomfortable or depressed this has
become easier and easier with the advent
of working or attending classes from
home so in a nutshell humans suffer in
an environment that differs considerably
from their ancestral habitat food is
another big contributor to the overall
decline in Western health despite the
fact that we have health professionals
and self-proclaimed nutritionists
running around telling us what's healthy
and what's not there's still an obesity
epidemic
high rates of diabetes and heart disease
and a prevalence of preventable
nutritional deficit disorders why is
that of course part of it can be chalked
up to lack of willpower no amount of
good dietary information is going to
prevent you from eating that third
brownie if you really want to another
aspect of the problem is that we're
surrounded by options our ancestors
didn't have foods that have only been
around for a few decades
if that consider the case of one of our
primate cousins mocha low the gorilla
mocha low lives at the Cleveland
Metroparks Zoo and his condition baffled
zookeepers and doctors for quite some
time in 2005 when a 21 year old gorilla
in mocha lowe's group died the staff
began to work on ways to improve the
remaining gorillas health mocha low was
overweight had high blood pressure
elevated cholesterol and high
triglycerides he was 22 at the time
which roughly equates to an American
male in his 50s who often suffer similar
conditions it was bizarre because mocha
low obviously didn't smoke drink or eat
fast food five times a week on the
contrary his diet was carefully crafted
by health experts the zookeepers
compared mocha low and his group to wild
gorillas to try to determine just what
was causing such health issues in the
end they changed the gorillas diet from
nutrient-rich Gorilla Biscuits
to foods more similar to what gorillas
eat in the wild they bought diverse
vegetables from the local supermarket
and within a week mocha lowe's bad
habits of laziness regurgitation pulling
out his hair it had all improved or
vanished entirely the gorillas were also
less bored
it took them much longer to eat all the
vegetables than it did their Gorilla
Biscuits
despite eating twice the amount of
calories as their previous diet over the
next few months mocha low lost 70 pounds
and stabilized around a healthy weight
the same general rule applies to just
about every species we thrive when we
mimic our ancestral biological diet
that's not to say that modern
nutritional knowledge is wrong just that
some of it doesn't reflect a
hunter-gatherer lifestyle the biggest
culprits are industrial foods sugars and
seeds as a rule of thumb if it's made in
a factory contains lots of ingredients
you can't pronounce or doesn't spoil you
probably shouldn't eat it or drink it in
the case of sugary beverages like soda a
study on the diets of 229 foraging
societies determined that nearly 75% of
them obtained more than half of
calories from animal meat of course this
isn't your average American Franken cow
but natural non-medicated animals in
another study of the few remaining
modern hunter-gatherer tribes food
groups were carefully weighed and
measured seven of the nine groups
obtained over 50% of their dietary
calories from meat and insects for
plants starchy roots and tubers were
most prevalent accounting for about 15%
of calories and less than 10% from
fruits in all but three of the tribes
these modern-day hunter-gatherers get
most of their calories from meat but eat
more plants overall because of their
relatively low calorie content without
exception these tribes have much lower
rates of heart disease and related
afflictions and obesity and diabetes are
essentially non-existent then there's
movement
today's Western society is largely
sedentary which is obviously in stark
contrast to the lifestyle our ancestors
lived thanks to the Agricultural
Revolution and eventually the Industrial
Revolution we didn't have to chase down
our food anymore we could grow it or
produce it from strange-sounding
ingredients in a factory but before all
that took place early humans would move
around a lot the hunters would cover
large distances to find food then they'd
have to carry their kills back to camp
gatherers would forage for berries
collect wood for fires and often they
would tend to the children there was
very little sitting around in this
primitive society by comparison we do a
whole lot of sitting today we sit in our
cars on the way to work sit at our desk
until quitting time sit in the car again
sit in front of the TV for an hour or so
and then go to sleep and do it all over
again many modern fitness experts will
tell you that you need to go to a gym
four days a week to be healthy but just
look back to our ancestors they didn't
have a bench press but they were all
functionally strong people think back to
the last time you did yard work or
helped a friend move or just walked
around a park you felt better after
right maybe physically tired but your
mental state was improved humans are
wired for physical activity in the past
we had to stay active to survive and our
brains rewarded us for it just like our
habitat and our diet humans thrive when
we mimic our ancestors lifestyle all of
our modern technology has given a lot of
people a greater quality of life in
terms of financial success and overall
for it but there's no denying our modern
lifestyle has also been a detriment to
our health the rate at which we are
advancing and outpacing evolutions
ability to keep up has been a giant leap
for mankind
but a step backwards for man it's no
wonder so many of us are overweight or
depressed when we tend to live like
captive gorillas so while yes we should
enjoy all of our modern conveniences
always remember that were driven by
evolution and biology and that maybe it
wouldn't be such a bad idea to go for a
walk outside the most common questions I
get asked regarding my videos are what
software do you use and where did you
learn to edit believe it or not I went
to school for broadcast journalism and
minored in film production I learned a
lot about After Effects there but coming
back to live on camera work for this
video made me realize just how out of
practice I am luckily for me I can brush
up on my camera skills with Skillshare
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators featuring over
16,000 classes in video production and
editing graphic design photography and
more anyone can take a class try a
project or even teach a class themselves
Premium Membership begins around $10 a
month for unlimited access to everything
as a little thank you for watching my
videos skill share is offering a two
month free trial for the first 500
people who sign up using the link below
you can use those two months to learn an
awesome new skill that you can use to
market yourself create a business or
even start your own YouTube channel like
I did there's no better time than now to
take that first step towards learning
that skill you've always dreamed of
having and since it's completely free to
try you have nothing to lose be one of
the first five hundred to sign up using
the link in the description and start
your two month free trial with
Skillshare I decided to try a new format
for this video so make sure to let me
know what you think in the comments
below if you enjoyed this video consider
subscribing to support second thought
and stay up to date with the latest
content you can watch the rest of my
videos by clicking here or if you're in
the mood for something a little
different
come check out my new gaming channel by
clicking here thanks for watching and
I'll see you in the next video